et bien de lourdes restrictions sont
mises en place en espagne
le couvre feu nocturne reste la
principale mesure prise par le
gouvernement pour tout le pays sauf les
îles canaries
alors il peut s'appliquer de 23 heures à
6 heures mais ce sont les régions qui
peuvent ajuster les horaires c'est le
juge nécessaire
par exemple en catalogne il s'applique
de 22h à 6h alors le gouvernement
espagnol souhaite également restreindre
la mobilité entre les régions d'espagne
mais à nouveau ce sont les communautés
autonomes qui peuvent décider celle
l'appliquent ou non car la volonté de
l'espagne et de laisser le choix aux
communautés autonomes de prendre des
décisions pour les principales mesures
alors les bars et restaurants devront
fermer plus tôt pour s'adapter au
couvre-feu
même si certains régions les ont déjà
complètement fermée comme la catalogne
et la navarre
alors l'état d'urgence prévoit également
de restreindre à la capacité d'accueil
dans des lieux fermés de réduire les
groupes dans les espaces publics comme
privés car le chef du gouvernement
espagnol pedro sanchez indiqué que le
pays vit une situation extrême alors
c'est l'instruction s'applique pour une
durée minimum de 15 jours un bilan sera
effectué toutes les deux semaines
l'état d'urgence sera appliquée jusqu'en
mai 2021